let's do a semi-hard segue into the
story about maxine waters because it's
sad funny it's sad funny
maxine waters warns reporter over la
homeless story you'll hurt yourself but
the real the real bit here is that she
told homeless people to go home
so let me let me get there they say
maxine waters tried to stop the
publication of a news story about the l
about los angeles homeless crisis this
week reportedly telling in la tron uh la
los angeles times scribe
you'll hurt yourself
and the community trying to put this
together investigative reporter connor
sheets detailed a march 25th incident in
south la where hundreds of homeless
people tried to obtain section 8 housing
vouchers after being misled by social
media rumors the would-be applicants
crashed an event held by non-profit
advocacy group fathers and mothers who
care which had been meant to help the
unhoused obtain emergency shelter
at one point waters told the crowd i
want everybody to go home triggering an
angry response we don't got no home
that's why we're here one member of the
crowd yelled back according to the la
times what home we gonna go to
this is insane la is is the nightmare
dystopia we read about as kids that we
were warned about
the politicians yelling at homeless
people to go home the homeless people
just everywhere skid row expanding drugs
and feces all over the place
california is a wasteland tomorrow
snopes is going to be like well
technically she didn't say which home
they should go so the underpass does
count
yeah she met their tent she will she she
should i love she could have been
referring to someone else's house here's
what i love i love when these leftists
post photos from like the mountains of
california and they're and they'll say
things like those conservatives
you know smack talk in california this
is what it's really like if you got
money right exactly it's like you go to
the palisades and you're looking at the
pch the pacifico's highway and you're
like look how beautiful this place is
sure just like an elysium that's the
french
i'm sure they're looking around like
what's wrong with with our with our
country everything's beautiful here
where rich people live it's like being a
multi-millionaire receiving experimental
treatment for your disease and being
like huh people claim that our health
care system isn't good
check this out yeah it's it's just
imagine it's it's the hunger games man
the people in the capital are drinking
it because to vomit to keep eating and
they're like what's wrong everything's
great life is good huh it's like yo uh
people are like living in their own
waste i'm taking dumps in the street i
guess a nice piece of news out of this
is michael shellenberger who's been on
the show before he's running for
governor california governor and he's
focused heavily on the on the homeless
population and helping clean them yeah
but you know look as much as i can
appreciate it if somebody wanted to
become mayor of a garbage dump i'm going
to be like bro good luck i guess yeah
yeah because rogan he was on rogan a
couple days ago and he said rogue was
like what just focus on la first and
he's like la's like
too far gone to starbucks he didn't i
don't know if he said too far but he's
like we'll start small and then we can
succeed then we'll go to l.a it would be
what if he went on rogan and he was like
well actually my job my plan is to
segment la and san francisco and push
them into the pacific and then instantly
the collective poverty and problems and
and everything that's wrong the
corruption uh will drop dramatically in
in in california so you know just like a
blood transfusion yeah well no it's like
you know it's like but with people
instead of mopping off the malignancy
yeah yeah exactly we can also build
islands i also it's so
rich too because it's the people from
california who have these really big
great creative ideas about how we can
fix the rest of the country even though
nowhere is really quite as bad as
california i think it's too big and well
it's it's also funny because they're
they're constantly complaining about
florida they're constantly complaining
about what goes on in florida while
their country where their state is
falling apart it's like well i don't
know desantis has not indicated any
ambitions to try to change how things
are done in california i'm pretty sure
he's just going to let that dumpster
fire burn we we we joke about california
kicking off la but what if ron desantis
was like we're going to separate florida
from the rest of this country you know
only by only by a few hundred feet so
that florida is sovereign and protected
and we don't have to worry about a moat
around that right
hungry alligators electric eels and he
can sell it around like an alligator
like sanctuary projects
please don't feed the alligators don't
do it
um
please don't feed the alligators
and then you gotta have a wall with a
moat with another wall with another moat
with another wall so yeah if you go off
the wall you just fall into the mode so
this is what's funny because they
actually claimed trump proposed a a moat
with full of alligators which he clearly
didn't do
it's just the funniest i just you know
always but you know it's an even dumber
border security idea telling them all
that they can get free health care if
they come here and like having our
politicians argue that we should look
look at this is devon who crosses the
border
story with maxine waters a bunch of
homeless people were told you could show
up and then maxine waters just yells at
him tells him to go home so just disper
i mean she's so dis uh i don't know
connected i guess from
humanity she yelled at him she said
excuse me there's nobody in washington
who works for their people any effing
harder than i do i don't want to hear
this no no no here's the thing maxine
maxine when you're surrounded by
homeless people and you yell at them to
go home and then when they get mad you
say hey hey nobody fights harder than me
it's like she's like do you know how
hard i have it yeah right dude i don't
know what my life is
uh i was seeing did you guys see the uh
california
are just going to start paying everyone
400 bucks rebate taxes well it's about
tax plan they're thinking about it i
mean talk about it just this is another
throwing money at third grade yeah it's
about time california spent some time
i'm so concerned for that state i do
think it's too big and like the northern
california is way different it's like
redwoods and trees well maybe not i
think there are the redwoods in norcal i
haven't been up that far in california
but it's like lush uh down south it's a
desert it's they're two completely
different environment it might kind of
work it's true might be worse david
jefferson or whatever you know that's a
proposal yeah new york state all these
bigger states with the the majority blue
they're looking to do that let's let's
put all cities in bubbles and their
jurisdiction extends within their city
and nothing else
if we you know what's really funny
economic forum yeah we should we should
just uh we should we should abolish
states and go county only
yeah so our all everything should be
done by county because then you'd see
how quickly the uh the progressive
agenda evaporates they they have uh
highly dense populations of people who
are stacked on top of each other in in
concrete jungles that smell like sour
milk and they all share this you know
similar ideology
and then you look at rural areas and its
disparate ideologies differing views in
different areas because people are more
spread out yeah in the city you smell
fumes carbon monoxide and stuff you're
constantly breathing it in so no wonder
they want to
gas a carbon tax and reduce emissions
well ian i mean breathing in those
toxins it leads to really good ideas it
leads to you having really good ideas
this is the problem with in my opinion
the majority of democrats
when i come out to the middle of nowhere
and i see like a pig farmer he's like
look you know i i i don't care what you
do in the cities
you know whatever i raise pigs my pigs
stink don't come out here if you don't
like the pig stink and i'm like i get it
i won't the city people do two things
they say
we live in a city people shouldn't be
allowed to make things smell like pig so
we're to ban pig farming in utah and
you're like wait wait hold on that
doesn't affect you anyway you don't live
there and they're like well i don't want
someone raising pigs near me it's like
bro no one's raising pigs in new york
well we're going to ban raising pigs
anyway for the whole nation it's what
they're doing with guns like yo
ricky john and and uncle billy up in the
mountains of west virginia need guns
because there's predators there's bears
there's banditos and you're like i'm in
new york i have police ban guns for
everyone they they look at these
problems and think the solution is
nationwide for everybody because they
assume everywhere in the country must be
a dense urban population well then and
then the process of creating their
solution they end up inevitably causing
more problems down the road so they ban
pigs right and then like five years
later they're like
why is pork and ham and bacon
everything's so expensive so then then
they pass the pork subsidy and start
giving out checks to people to be able
to buy pork not understanding they
caused the problem but they got to ship
all the pigs to china first so we can
get our pork from china so we have to
smell it over here they're like they're
like first of all it is an ethical abuse
to kill pigs we will only eat pigs
killed on chinese soil and then they
send the pigs over their necks now my
soul is clean to make this real this is
literally the conversation that is
exactly happening with the gas exactly
this is literally what's happening we
have been told that we can't have an
american oil supply because it's going
to kill the environment in return we
need to release the million barrels from
our strategic oil reserve and also we're
going to keep on buying foreign oil from
we talked about venezuela yeah a country
that hates us and is a socialist
dictatorship well but empowering
venezuela is a good thing it's a good
thing it's brilliant today the um there
was a really good babylon bee headline
biden plans to sell alaska to russia so
we can drill for oil there oh my god
that hurts
well this is the current state of
america but i i do have confidence you
know that uh
freedom is winning yeah human ingenuity
is amazing dude it's amazing for
hundreds of thousands of years i mean we
only have recorded history for like ten
thousand eight thousand years but man
amazingly oh how they overcome but i
mean you do see empires overturned and
conquered and they don't really talk
about the death that comes along with
that because it's all those people died
they didn't get to write the history
books like it's not a popular thing to
to remind people about but that's the
part of this that i don't i don't want
to see you know weird i mean that's how
biden keeps on going back to this too
like well when we write the history
books how do you want to be remembered
and like that seems to be a reoccurring
yes argument you notice that and like
all the time yeah but it's very hegelian
yeah it's gonna be really funny when in
50 years there's going to be a teacher
talking to the kids in in their digital
like you know hologram class and they're
going to be like who can tell me about
the leaders of the 21st century me me
they were vapid self-interested egotists
who are desperate to be acknowledged by
us in the future that's correct and what
do we say to that those people suck yeah
dude that's so true they're such pikmis
they're like come on future people tell
me i was great you tell me i was good
yeah that's really what it is it was
amazing i think oh what do you say biden
like grabbed the wheel of the car
because he i think he was like i gotta
do this for my own posterity and then
all he's doing is ruining his own
posterity by being um you know
unqualified essentially to run the
country at the moment you know what it
is look i look at japan when uh the the
fukushima fukushima reactors you know
melted down or whatever the disaster a
bunch of old japanese a bunch of
japanese seniors were like i've lived my
life i'm gonna sacrifice myself to save
the next generation
and these elderly people were
volunteering to go into the reactors to
try and get under control and many of
them died
i actually uh the the the fixer that um
guided me and luke rodkowski into
fukushima she was a bit older and she
was bringing journalists and people in
there to so that people could find out
what's going on she died of cancer wow
so these are the older people being like
no no it's fine like she wasn't even
that old you know but these are people
who are like i've lived a long life i'm
going to do what i can now because if i
die the younger generation will survive
they used to have i look at i look at
what's going on in the united states and
in europe and it's the opposite exactly
it's old people being like children
should be should be restricted and put
in plastic boxes so that i'm not
inconvenienced it used to be vexed if
they're under the age of five like your
grandma is safe there was a kingdom of
heaven like it used to be that you
believed that if you died doing
something righteous that you'd be
rewarded and they told us that because
they probably wanted people to live like
that because it benefits society if the
old people will sacrifice themselves for
the young people uh it's very natural no
i think it was an emergent phenomenon i
don't think
there's people who believe that religion
was like powerful
leaders who were like i must trick the
people into believing this heaven no i
think people genuinely believed that
like yeah because you get the dmt rush
at the end of life people i see the
light at the end of the tunnel but look
it's actually really simple outside of
any theological argument or anything
like that
if you take two groups of people one
believes in being righteous and
honorable and the other doesn't which
one is more likely to survive that's a
good point catastrophe because the in
japan i don't know that they're
necessarily christian were they did they
do this there's some sort of honor code
apparently yeah it's a very honorific
culture well that's yeah yeah i mean
they used to they used to commit suicide
like i'm not going to pretend to be a
story on japan but you know people
understand the memes about seppuku and
the idea was if if you failed or if you
were dishonorable or something you'd
take your own life
now i think that's kind of horrifying
but imagine what happens then if you
have a group of scoundrels who are out
for each other and are warring with each
other and you have a group of people who
are like i'm going to sacrifice myself
for the greater good which one survives
in the long term well this goes back to
the point we brought up earlier about
education that's why there's such an
intense approach right now in the left
to control
what is and is not taught in government
schools and it's because you see the
kids who are raised by their parents who
have more of the religious backings
they're getting taught this at home the
the idea that there is something beyond
you in this present there is a future
that you're building for that you're not
even going to see one day whereas if the
left can take that and get rid of that
in the government schools at a young age
then they're basically undoing the work
that the parents have invested and it's
it's setting up to to your point the the
world view that goes into that instant
gratification without thinking of the
posterity what comes next
they're they're i feel like
the democrat side it's obviously not
literally every person but it's the
overwhelming majority are the people who
are like i hope future people like me
that's why they always say you're on the
wrong side of history it's like i'm not
motivated by what feature people think
you know imagine being someone in in
china in the early 1900s yeah you were
on the wrong side of history opposing
the murderous regime of of mao and the
gang of four or whatever but uh
today you're now on the right side of
history at least to us i'm sure in
communist china they still don't like
those who you know resisted they don't
like the people the government of taiwan
the actual government of china but
that's the point i don't care what you
think the right side of history is yeah
if these if these you know um uh
die cultists end up taking over and it
gets bad to the point where horrific
things are happening in this country and
i end up leaving
i'm not gonna be going around being like
i guess i was on the wrong side of
history i'm gonna be like my country was
taken over by psychopaths
yeah exactly like oh man i wish i would
have been on the right side of that one
because like just because you lost
doesn't mean think about it but but
listen to how
realize how they think then yeah they're
legitimate legitimately there are
democrat activists who thought it's not
right but it will win
that's why they decided to opt to
supporting dicultism well i just want to
say if i were teleported to the future
and everyone was transgender it was a
communist country where children didn't
pick their identity until they were 12
years old i would just make fun of them
i would hope they didn't like me i would
hope they didn't consider me
just go back in time and say we got to
fight for what we believe in yeah but i
guess my point is there's actually an
arrogance to saying i want to be on the
right side of the his of history not
just in the sense that you are presuming
that you would be for doing what you're
aiming to do but also you're judging all
of the past and saying well if we as
modern people liked what you did then
you were one of the good guys so my
aspiration should be to have future
people judge me well who says moral
erosion doesn't occur in some areas
there are things we look back on as
being horrible that we're actually
better and there are things that we look
on today as being wonderful that are
actually horrible imagine siding with
some politics just because you think
it's the one that's going to win yeah
like i'd rather be correct imagine could
you imagine being someone who like made
very popular youtube videos and like
song parodies and then end up taking
them down because you were scared that
you know the left would you get banned
or they would they would come after you
and that you you genuinely just thought
it's not worth fighting for these things
i think are true because i'll lose
imagine being that kind of person people
are scared too i mean i i went up so as
you mentioned earlier in my day job i'm
a sales executive and i do a lot of
talking about business technology cyber
security and i went to wisconsin i was
talking at a small business owners
conference and um we were just talking
about cyber security stuff at the very
end of the q a this guy comes up and
he's standing there and uh he goes brian
you're you're very political and yet you
also do a lot in the private sector how
do you bridge the two worlds and it kind
of caught me off guards i'm there for a
conversation about cyber security and i
was like honestly like at the end of the
day you just you just got to be your
authentic self and like say this is who
i am this is why i believe
and i just i firmly believe that good
people will find good people and that
good people will bring out the good in
people so
instead of hiding what you believe and
and keeping that back i think we should
lead with
our values lead with our ideas and and
focus on building things that are
outside of the the traditional
mainstream getting away from the
explaining right yeah good ideas don't
require force that's right um available
at brian show.com forward slash shop and
if you wanted to create a better future
the opportunity is there right now you
can start to build these solutions i
mean i had a guy in my show he's the ceo
of a pediatric cancer research company
and they have not only created a system
to get donations through cryptocurrency
but now they're using blockchain
technology to help increase the research
efficiencies of
you name the the focus
and he's talking about how they're
chicago schools that are they do
research and how they were getting
siloed into you know i'm focusing on
this project i'm focusing on this
project and they're a mile apart from
each other they're doing the same
project they had no idea this entire
time so taking it out of these silos
putting it onto blockchain and now
creating an open environment where we
can get things advanced faster research
done more quick and we're seeing more
people's lives being saved as a result
of that and that's all because somebody
decided i'm going to go by my values i
think that blockchain
and nfts has a amazing opportunity to
just change the game and they they
jumped on that and now they're actually
making things better they're saving
little kids lives that's a big deal
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you